- Que ce soit de Colombie,
de Toronto ou de Madagascar...
MAHALEO, touriste de Madagascar
- C'est vraiment agréable
et ça coïncide aussi
avec le... la thématique
de réconciliation.
- Des visiteurs de partout
dans le monde ont marché dans
s s s rues de Québec à l'occasin
de la venue du pape François.
ROBERT MERCURE, directeur
général, Destination Québec Cité
- C'est tellement une belle
opportunité de visibilité.
Aussi, on est trocococcupés,
on est pas mal à pleine
capacité comme destination.
Mais la visibilité mondiale,
on peut pas acheter ça.
Ça vaut des millions
et millions de dollars.
- Cette visibilité mondiale,
elle est notamment venue
de la part de nombreux
asasas internationaux.
Plus du tiers des
500 journalistes accrédités
pour l'événement viennent
de l'extérieur du Canada.
Mais malgré tout, cela n'a pas
empêché le secteur touristique
de recevoir un peu moins de
visiteurs que prévu. Encore
hier, près de 20 % des chambres
étaient toujours disponibles.
ALUPA CLARKE, président, Assoc.
hôtelière de la région uéuéuébec
- Il y a peut-être moins de
pèlerins qu'on le prévoyait.
Est-ce que c'est dû peut-être
à une septième vague? Il y a
certaines personnes qui ont
annulé, hier, leurs réservations
en disant peut-être qu'il y
aurait trop de circulation
ou de problématiques.
- Ce constat, un restaurateur
de la Grande Allée l'a
particulièrement ressenti.
PHILIPPE DESROSIER
propriétaire, brasserie INOX
- Si je me fie à nos...
notre achalandage normalement
dans la construction, c'est
80 % de diminution, là, facile.
- La rue a été fermée plusieurs
heures hier et aujourd'hui
pour des questions de sécurité.
rererestaurateur a donc reçu
moins de clients.
- C'était tranquille pour nous.
Je pense qu'on l'a vu un peu,
c'était compliqué de se rendre
en ville. C'était beaucoup
barricadé, puis c'est
totalement comprenable.
Le pape a besoin d'une sécurité.
Pour nous, c'était dur de
quantifier. On avait mis des
employés. Finalement, on a coupé
beaucoup plus que d'autre chose.
- Si les touristes n'ont pas
été aussi nombreux qu'espéré,
les dirigeane e e Destination
Québec Cité se consolent
et espèrent que la venue du
souverain pontife sera bénéfique
lors des années à venir.
Ici Jérémie Camirand,
Radio-Canada, à Québe